And on pages, on social media like Facebook or Instagram and snapchat.
People only post things that are happy,...
...like eating food, which is what I post a lot, yeah...
....or I just like traveling and this is how people see.
You know, just me having fun and me climbing.
But in reality, this is sort of what happens.
Yeah, I hate it so much.
From timing I've learned that like homework...
...is sort of a part of 99% to success...
...and I've learned that nothing worth doing is going to be easy.
But the effort that you put into it, it's going to pay off at the end...
...and I think that it's important to endure and climb through your problems.
And well, failure is a huge part of success.
And well, you don't have to be a rock climber to understand this.
But I like to think that everyone in this room is a climber.
Think about it, let's do a V14 because after all, we are all climbers at heart.
Thank you.